greetings from podcastville
it's monday november 16th uncle joey's
joint is brought to you by
blue chew guys remember when you were
[__] and your dick was always standing
at attention
ready to give somebody a stabbing yeah
those days are long gone you could just
pray
but listen if you got weak wood uncle
joey's got the fix
blue chew it's the first chewable dick
pill
same fda approved act to give the
ingredients as viagra
and cialis this isn't the horny goat
weed you get from [__] the corner
store
this is science and right now
blue chew has a special offer off it
off for the for the uncle joint
family you ready visit bluechew.com
that's bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment
free when you press in code joey
bluechu.com just pay five dollar
shipping
and again that's blue like the color of
your dick when you eat one of these
pills
that'll be popping like a [__]
missile bluetooth.com
use code joey and we thank you for
continuing to sponsor the show
the church is also brought to you by
hydrant
these days are getting shorter and it's
getting colder outside
and we can feel our energy is getting
sapped
don't don't [__] with that [__] don't
get sick this winter hydrating
is the best thing you can do for your
health that's why i start my day
with hydrate the 100 milligram caffeine
it helps you hydrate
faster after a workout i take a little
bike ride
take a little walk with my daughter this
helps uncle joey
feel tip top magoo i like the different
flavors orange raspberry
lemonade and lemon they're tremendous i
bring them to the gym with me right
after i finish working out
i drop one for an extra boost try the
hydrogen immunity
they got all the vitamins you want a b6
b12 cd plus ginger and turmeric
and you can drink it hot or cold i got a
special offer for you today
25 off your first order that's right
25 called up drink
com slash joey and the code joey and
check out
this bag is filled with all different
flavors
see how they come so this bag has
i don't know how many little baggies in
here 30 packs
that'll keep you hydrated the whole
winter so right now
go to drink hydrant.com joey enter promo
code joey
and get 25 off your first order because
let me tell you some health
is woke don't risk it get 25 off at
drink hydrate
dot com slash joey and the church is
also brought to you by
mack welton listen a couple weeks from
now is black friday whether you're
shopping for yourself
or another man in your life maybe you
swing both ways i don't know what you're
doing
but the only place you need to shop is
mack weldon they got the best
of all things socks shirts hoodies
underwear polo shorts and right now they
got a special offer they got the all
black pack
it comes with a t-shirt underwear and
socks all inside a backpack
that's worth more than 150 dollars but
black friday you get it for 98 bucks
to grab your exclusive all black pack
for 98
while supplies last visit mackwalden.com
slash joint j-o-i-n-d
and pressing code joint you also get 20
off your first order that's
macweldon.com
joint promo code joint for 20
off your first order and the all black
pack for 98
let me tell you something mac weldon's
got some tremendous long underwear
and if you know anything about me i'm
getting my balls nice and warm for the
winter
so go to mackwaldom.com
joint promo code joey
let's get this [__] party
started now you understand me
bam
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday november 16th
we're at the halfway point of the month
it's a beautiful [__] monday to see
you
listen last week the podcast what the
[__] they were you know what i'm saying
but that's what's great about monday
it's a whole new week
with a whole new set of [__] rules i
had a great week last week i had a great
weekend
i hope you guys had a great time we're
safe you're healthy
you know whatever the [__] is happening
is gonna happening
we gotta push [__] forward i had an
interesting week because i told you
lately
that since i've been doing uh since we
moved it's gonna be [__]
three months on thursday since i moved
and every week my anxiety gets a little
better and better and better
last week mike comes over and we're
doing one of the podcasts
and i was looking for my weed and i
found like maybe a jar
with the nug tremendous [__] weed
but when i looked to see where the [__]
the other weed was
i couldn't find my [__] wheat so i
said you know what
it's probably one of the closets it's
it's around here somewhere
right so for a few days i'm chomping off
this
[__] bud and i'm like i still haven't
found my weed yet
i looked over here i looked over there i
looked over here
my weed is nowhere to be found i wanted
my old luggage
you got to remember i still haven't
found the [__] pipe my favorite
[__] pipe of all time i have not
found in three [__] months it's here
trust me it's here i just haven't found
it all right
so i can't find this [__] i got this
[__] half ounce
of this [__] uh they give this [__]
to like hemophiliacs and stuff like that
this is the weed they give you before
you die this [__] was tremendous it was
like white
so i put a half ounce of this away and i
can't remember where the [__] it is it
was like to break into emergency
situations
you ever see this and that [__] the
glass don't break unless emergency
situations so
i called my guy he goes bro your
delivery's on the way
but you can't make the he can't make the
drop off till friday i go [__] friday
i'm not going to [__] make it to
[__] friday so
i had some weed wednesday i i scared now
you're looking at me going joey what the
[__] do you do with all that wheat
i smoked it i'm not running a weed
museum i made a [__] smoke reefer i'm
not running [__] high times
looking at buds dreaming about [__]
california and then
i'm smoking you know throughout the day
i smoke and i'm not
since i don't have my pipe i gotta smoke
[__] joints
which kills my [__] reefer so finally
wednesday i call a few friends
i got one guy for sure up north and
here's the funny thing i saw him that
afternoon
and he authored me some and i said nah
i'm good so
i [__] come home and i get and i look
around wednesday
i can't find my [__] house i called a
friend of mine down here
and he goes let me make a call they're
gonna have my block sell some
i go look at me [__] looking for
jersey weed so i called my brother i got
a brother who's been smoking i've been
smoking weed with him
since i was 16. he's a professional head
professional doesn't drink
doesn't do pills doesn't do coke his
whole life is dedicated to [__]
reefer
so i finally broke down and i called
them up and i go hey man i'm gonna bind
you gotta help me can i get a couple
joints from here so
my mule gets in he goes no worries come
down
so you'll give me your address i don't
know where the [__] he lives close by i
think 25 minutes
i got in the [__] car i go let me eat
i didn't want to be a goblin i just went
to the gym
and i hadn't smoked if i don't smoke i
get no appetite in the [__] morning
believe it or not
so i get the [__] uh i get and i eat
my lunch with my wife
a little cop salad whatever the [__] she
made i get in the car and i hit the
[__] uh
nine south whatever and i get to his
house
jesus christ he takes me downstairs to
the basement he's like
pick whatever the [__] you want he
opened up a bag it had gorilla bag on it
tremendous it was this [__] big
he had like 10 different ounces in there
i said i don't even need an ounce he
goes take whatever the [__] you want
he opened up a drawer it was just
different rolling papers
this is the type of professional this
guy is he ain't [__] around
he had [__] moon rocks he had this he
had that he had more [__] than people in
california got
and he's a jersey guy so i said listen i
don't need any other stuff
i go just give me a couple of buds like
some reefer
i'll take moon rocks because you can
sprinkle the moon rocks in your [__]
joint
and see the devil well i [__] get
home
not so sorry i get home i come
downstairs
i roll my first joint i put the moon
rocks in there
i get so [__] high i come in there's
a box
the mule came a day early it was better
than me and
when i was high on the [__] mule on
the moon rocks
i said wait a second there's one place i
didn't check and i went and hit that
place
and there was the half ounce of reef you
see i'm saying so if you lose something
you got to get as high as you are when
you hit it
to find it that's the moral of the
[__] story see i was walking around
all [__] straight for three days
mikey you [__] laugh it's true i even
hit mikey up
and mike is like i got like three nugs
myself i go what type of christian would
i be if i took your last drunken three
nights and i appreciate that i'm not
gonna take some of these last three nugs
because i knew i had to weed in here
there's nothing worse than [__]
knowing you got something
and you can't find it you know it's in
the [__] house somewhere
i ran out of places where the [__] i hid
stuff like that
today we have a zoom you know i hate
[__] zoom
but you gotta do them from time to time
we gotta break up the monotony i got the
beautiful
and talented and [__] uh
she's the real deal i got miss drea d
mateo waiting in the background on
[__] zoom ready to go but i want to
talk to you a little bit it's [__]
monday morning
i want to make sure you're up to par
make sure you're up to [__] tip top
two conditions
you know everybody's going through it we
don't know when it's going to end
you know we don't know there's a vaccine
now i gotta take a shot
and put [__] ice cream in it i think
it's gonna be it's a hundred degrees
below [__] zero
that means my arm is gonna go numb for
[__] two times
for me to [__] beat the vaccine and i
don't i don't like [__] needles trust
me
i think live nation put a thing out
there you're not gonna be able to go to
that concerts without a [__] card
i already got a fake card working and
i'm saying we're already working it
a fake card i don't give a [__] oh you
guys get vaccinated
i'll keep my distance and when it's time
hopefully this [__]
virus will go away and uncle joe will be
ready to do his [__] thing i'm not
getting no [__] ice cube shot in my
arm
i still got two shots on [__] hold
which i'm not taking
i don't like [__] needles at all and
i'm not in the mood for a new vaccine
right out of the [__] top i see when
i'm gonna wake up without a [__] hand
i'll wake up with the guy like from
[__] into the dragon i got no hands i
gotta put different [__] attachments
on my arm
i'm not going for that one if you want
to take the shot be my [__] guest
me i'm a gentleman i just won't go the
[__] out i just won't go out
i'm my business or whatever until they
come up with a pill
but i'm not shooting ice cubes in my
[__] veins
are you [__] nuts to put 21 days
apart
i barely give blood i [__] [__]
myself now i got to give you
i got to let you shoot a [__] ice
cube in my [__] arm
you didn't know about that it's like man
they got to keep it chilled i thought it
was bleach
it's like [__] it's like [__]
going to crowd therapy shooting crowd
therapy in you
that's what i need right three times two
times 21 days apart
for the shingles it's 21 days apart
looks like i'm getting [__] shingles
you know what i'm saying because i'm not
going down there
i don't give a [__] jack it's funny how
life
uh this thursday's gonna be three months
since we're all gone and everything like
that i think i left a week before rogue
i woke up uh yesterday morning
and i'm going through whatever i'm
playing with my daughter and i see a
a youtube clip about did rogan
abandon his friends
what what is the [__] what what
why don't people just leave joe rogan
the [__] alone he's down there in austin
texas
in the capitol cove and he ain't
bothering nobody he ain't bothering
nobody i gotta tell you something
joe has not abandoned his friends ari
went to [__] whatever
duncan is in north carolina i'm in
jersey
you know brian counts in his own [__]
dilemmas
which i wish him all the luck in the
world whatever's going on with him
brendan schaub is in la you know bird is
in la
tom segura is in la rogan didn't abandon
his friends
in fact i talked to rogan twice a week
and i gotta be honest with you guys
he sounds better than [__] ever
and he sounds happy than ever and i
think like
like i knew him when he moved to
colorado and he came back
you know i've known him for 20 something
years he sounds like a million [__]
bucks
he sounds like a guy that just got a
hundred million dollars
that's what he sounds like he doesn't
give a [__] he doesn't have a worry in
the world
you know i spot i called him yes on a
saturday morning
we must have talked for 20 minutes it
was all laughter
and i gotta tell you i think he got over
it also we all got that stink off as the
last tank
and we're seeing the other side of the
[__] mountain now so it's kind of
[__] nice
nobody's suffering nobody's avoiding
anybody
red band is moving tony hinchcliffe is
moving
i'm sure i'll be down there at some time
to do a [__] podcast in the new year
once the numbers clear up or whatever i
know you did a show last week
with uh ron white and tony hinchcliffe
ron white is enthused listen man
for some guys this is just a breather
we're not going
listen yeah it took and broke my heart a
little bit
you know we can't do stand up every
night but i do know what it's coming
back
everything's gonna come back in time and
then a different in a different style
we're gonna have
life is gonna be a little different it's
gonna be different from musicians it's
gonna be different for artists
it's gonna be different for plumbers
it's gonna be different for customer
service people
we're just gonna have to [__] work
around it you know
they're saying the vaccine will be at
the end of november god bless you
as they say good luck to everybody i
don't know what's going to happen but
you got to keep your channel but to be
honest here rogan never abandoned his
friends
we just moved away and we're all doing
our own things
and we're all looking into the future
and seeing what the [__] my next move is
i'm still a [__] i'm more of a
stand-up now than i ever was
i will be at uncle vinnie's wednesday
night
and [__] next wednesday night the
night before thanksgiving
and i just picked up three dates in
december i'm still doing stand-up
i'm just not gonna tour i'm not really
in the mood to get on any [__] planes
right now that's it
but besides that i'm still a [__]
standard i'm just taking a breather
i'm just living life and i'm trying to
gain more material better material
to come back and spank you [__]
with you know what i'm saying
i mean uh i could come on here and be
[__] soggy [__]
and tell you about all the bad things
that are going on in the world but you
don't want to hear them
you know about them all you can worry
about is what the [__] you're doing
that's it that's i'm [__] happy right
now i haven't been this happy
in a long time yeah i missed stand up i
missed some airports
i know my wife would like to see me get
the [__] out of here from time to time
but hey this is the times this is what
we're doing right now
we're just collecting ourselves becoming
a little better
i'm hitting the gym three times a week
now i'm lifting weights i wasn't lifting
weights three
three [__] times a week i'm lifting
weights and
i found the jiu jitsu place that does
like [__] old man jiu jitsu
so i'm kind of excited about that it's
going to be a great winter what
whatever the [__] they do if they shut
us back down what do you mean do cry
i feel bad for my daughter but i already
have a backup plan set up we got a list
of parents
and now you'll be prepared so don't
worry about the lockdown
you know the numbers are getting out of
proportion in some states
they exceeded a million in [__] uh
in texas god knows what california is
doing god knows what florida doing
but if you're watching this you're alive
and uh maybe you had kovit
and maybe you got rid of it and maybe
it's [__] [__] and maybe it's just
[__] whatever the [__] it is i don't
have the answers to your problems
all i know is that we're here it's
monday and we got to be the best that we
can [__] be
you know again you know we're so bored
we're still living in the [__] past i
see this week people are taking digs
at the leah and whatever listen that was
six [__] months ago
let it go if they haven't arrested
[__] uh
brian cowan then i don't know what to
tell you and
nobody's arresting crystalia so put it
behind you let's let these guys
move on heal and take care of whatever
problems they have
but kicking them when they're down ain't
gonna solve them right now
i mean uh what comics we're brotherhood
how dare us kick each other when we're
[__] down
like i said a couple weeks ago we're
turning into those [__]
jews during the holocaust turning on our
own people you can't turn on your own
people this is the time for us to get
closer
and united it's it's uh really funny i
talked to a friend of mine the other day
from l.a
i just called him to check in no names
and we were talking about jiu jitsu and
whatnot
and how his school has cut it down to
maybe
a 30-person call they haven't taken any
new students
but they all hang out amongst themselves
and it's made them stronger
and he thought that this [__]
uh lockdown would break him apart and
what happened he goes
no it's made us 30 people stronger
we hang out with each other we smoke pot
with each other we play music and hang
out with each other
we do outdoor activities with each other
and we're just with each other so we
make sure that none of us can get it
because we're just with each other
so it's a great way of looking at i was
kind of [__] happy
you know i talked to three or four
people at jiu jitsu on uh
schools nobody has gotten sick
so maybe exercise
is the [__] key i go to a gym they
keep the doors open there's never more
than six people in there
i wear a face mask but towards the end
of the gym a workout sometimes
i take the mesh the face mask off to
drink water
go to the back door get some [__] air
you know what knock on wood
i'm still [__] good i'm not in big
groups of people
i'm in little groups of people i hang
out uh sundays i go to jimmy florentines
i watch a little football
i get high with the boys i sit by the
back door we get
nice and ventilated so all i can do is
tell you is to [__] take care of
yourself
take your vitamins uh right write your
goals
i gotta let you [__] knows maybe i'm
gonna get twenty dollars
something always means something you're
like oh my palm [__] inches
i'm gonna find five dollars my nose
itches maybe i'll get covered on my dick
who the [__] knows
anyway listen without further ado here's
the zoom interview we did last week
with my girl drea di mateo i'm a fan of
hers
uh she went from the sopranos
working with david chase over the sons
of anarchy
to the couple seasons of senator hanecki
working up against jack
hornen aka jack stella she did a couple
years stint on joey
i mean this girl had a great
acting career and she's still not
[__] done yet
she's great she's funny uh we met
through aj soprano
and i love it at that i hope you enjoy
the interview uncle joey's showing
welcome to uncle joey's joint we've got
the beautiful the savage
dread d matteo a legend i love her
i have watched everything you're in from
the sopranos to joey
to the sons of anarchy and i got to tell
you you
uh hit the jackpot you had
you were you just tremendous you were
tremendous thanks joey
they call me uncle dre i know people
call you uncle joey right
right they call me freaking uncle dre
why is that i don't know because i'm a
filthy savage
oh you said savage
well as i said do you did you ever go to
an acting class
yeah right you went to an acting college
i didn't start out with it i grew i mean
i grew up with my mom who's a writer
she's a playwright and she taught
writing for years at hp studios so i
used to have to sit in her writing
classes
because i didn't have a babysitter on
certain days and i
had to listen to her teach writing so i
learned how to act listening to her
teach the writers because it's kind of
the same thing
um you know you want to keep everything
moving keep everything active
kind of thing but um then i went to
nyu film school because i hated
theater because i grew up in it so i did
the [__] you anti-theater
and went to film school but never to act
but then later on
years later when i when i stopped being
so freaking shy
i took an acting class i took a couple
i learned how to act on the song yeah
the sopranos was my acting class
that was some acting class that was my
acting class my real
that was that was a hell of an acting
class my friend
and that was that's acting 101 right
there you are with the best
it's true if i close my eyes i think
you're vinnie pastor
that's crazy isn't it you don't even
have to close my eyes
we just met recently we met about four
years ago at a movie premiere
and we didn't even say nothing to each
other we just hugged each other
like there was nothing to say we've been
hearing about each other for years you
know
well that's how it is between us you
know us weirdos
in this business
do you do you still see him at all um
i have i saw vinnie last year we we
gave an award at the mtv awards
okay um and uh when we were trying to
get him to do our podcast the gangster
goddess broadcast
um podcast it was hard to get in touch
with him
and i was like you know what [__] this
guy i'm bringing joey diaz on
and i'm going to say this is big [__]
[__] because if i can't get in touch
with this prick
i'm [__] just going to do that and
that's it
well i know he teaches an acting class
doesn't he
yes yes monday nights he used to
when i came here a year ago he was
teaching an acting class
with uh wife
oh really with maureen yes
yes on monday night somewhere
and i was tempted to go i was in town a
few weeks
i would have paid the drop in just to
you know sit in there and get all the
information
that ever got to me in time oh he's
awesome but yeah he's supposed to come
on our show
now he finally we finally got in touch
with each other
but um but now we're taking a hiatus so
i'm on your show instead that's it this
is why i love you now
you the sopranos ended you went to joey
that lasted that lasted a couple weeks
and then how did you stumble on sons of
anarchy
um funny i was just telling that story
um joey was a couple years
i didn't really want to do joey because
i was i didn't want to be typecast back
then i was
real you know precious about what being
an
actor instead of just being an actor
who's actually good at
talking like this for a living i was
good at doing that you know
but um joey dissolved
pretty quickly even though back then we
had millions of viewers
but because friends had 17 million
viewers
we had 14 million viewers that was low
today if you had 14 million viewers
forget about it
yeah it's a kick-ass show but um
yeah we were we had such high
expectations me coming from sopranos him
coming from friends
that nothing was measuring up but uh but
we definitely partied hard and had
had a [__] fantastic time um
sons of anarchy was because of john
lindsen
he's dirt he's a producer his dad is art
and they brought the idea to fx and with
the idea i was just playing a tiny cameo
who dies
in the pilot that was it and i was like
yeah of course i'll do that but it'll be
fun i'll
you know i'll die i'll od while i'm
pregnant why not that sounds
freaking awesome um and then they
asked me if i would stay once i said i
would do the pilot
and then john and art lindsen were no
longer a part of the project and i ended
up staying a little bit
but then i walked out because fx wanted
to cut my
pay in half and i was like you can't
offer me one
you know pay me one thing and then a
couple of weeks later tell me so we want
to cut your pay in half so i
i declined and um went into desperate
housewives instead
and then i became a fan of the show and
i called kurt and i was like dude
i'll come back for nothing let's just do
it
really yeah that's tremendous
yeah it was fun and you were there till
the end you wrote out
the sun with jimmy uh smith's
another killer that you were around yeah
yeah in the end in the end they had to
pay me though because
i could you know i i was never available
when they wanted me
because i came in and out a lot on the
show
um but in the end they were like we need
to nail you down as a series regular for
the final season i was like are you
kidding they're like yeah because you're
never in one
city as long as i know that you're going
to be here in l.a we'll just have to
nail you down i was like well then okay
then you gotta
you gotta really pay me this time so
and they hooked you up and you made
history again what a great
finale to that what a great finale to
the sopranos i mean
just two iconic shows man
yeah it was pretty cool dead and then
alive
i i survived in the end
when you look back your head must
explode
ah my head is exploding now
in this freaking quarantine and not
having worked for
a year and i wasn't working purposely
for a year before it
thinking i would definitely work the
year after and now we got stuck in this
and i haven't worked in a while so i'm
feeling it right now
and you have children yeah i'm a single
mom
and i take care of it take care of it
all by myself
so it's you know i work i just oh i only
work when i know i have to pay
for stuff you know so i haven't worked
in a while
and now i need to pay for stuff
so i'm [__]
well hopefully you'll land something man
because i don't know not in this class
you know they're shooting but it's tough
to shoot trey
i know it's really tough to shoot i i
i shot those last three days on the
the prequel of the sopranos it must have
cost them
an arm and a leg we each had a driver we
each had a floor on a hotel
you know there was nurses everywhere a
culvert
you know to do it the right way in this
climate it's just
unless you do it like tyler perry and
you stay
there for eight weeks what a good setup
yeah you're away from your family well
that's all the jobs that are coming my
way right now
i'd have to quarantine in canada for
seven months i'd have to quit
and my kids go with me everywhere and
they're like we really don't want to do
that and
they won't be able to see their dad for
months because he can't visit
you know everybody's got to be
sequestered like that and i can't i
can't do it so i'm kind of [__] right
now
yeah somebody just reached out about a
show in wilmington north carolina
for december and i'm like it's not going
to happen
yeah it's not going to i don't see it in
the winter time
no you know i see and then i got to have
an [__] coming back and
i got a seven-year-old dream i can't
believe
i was with my wife for 13 years nothing
happened
we had cats we had like eight cats
and one day i came home and she was
pregnant wait how old is she
please tell me she's 50 right now
oh okay so she was she 43.
she was 43 because i keep hoping i'm
gonna get pregnant by some miracle of
48.
oh that's tough that's tough if you
google it you have a heart attack
oh i know unless you have like nurses
like janet jackson
and they blow smoke in your [__] and
[__] like that
it's not it's not gonna work out for you
oh my god my great grandma my
grandmother had my father when she was
51.
wow you know us italians over here yeah
yeah i know
my friend's dad adamantly my friend's
dad had him when he was 74.
well but not the mom no my mom was like
48 or something
okay well there's hope for me still
there's hope for you
there's hope how many more do you want
how many more kids do you want
i would say one more but after after
this freaking quarantine with the kids
locked down like this maybe i'm
exaggerating
maybe i'll take a dog or a cat
this quarantine has been tough on the
kids and it's tough to find things to do
with them
you have a boy or girl i have a little
girl man
and when they told me that they were not
opening up the schools
i looked at my wife and i said we're out
of here we're so you were in la
and you left l.a to go back to germany
after 23 years
because of the because i mean why didn't
you want to see i'm
in a situation where i might have to
move right now but i'm thinking that
being in la is a blessing and i always
want to go back
east um but i feel like being in this in
this covid thing
it's way way way better being out here
because you could be outside it's warm
it's
you know what i mean no
dude why do you have to move because
i don't know if i could keep this fancy
place without working
i see what you're saying all right so i
keep getting friggin
for uh notifications about foreclosure
at this point
no oh yeah because we were part of the
forbearance thing
and um they're just we can't even get in
touch with the mortgage company
and they keep sending us certified
letters but nobody answers the phone
they keep saying we're trying to reach
you but nobody calls me
and nobody answers the phone and it's
it's a i'm in a mess
like it's not even because i'm not
paying a lot of the money is just not
even being applied
so we're kind of in a crazy and i've
been in this house for 17 years but i
always lived in new york anyway i lived
in my apartment that burned down in the
east village
i didn't stay out here but i was happy
for the first time
in this pandemic that i was in this
house
i was like thank god no as soon as they
said no school
i knew i was out of that i had a good
time
why would you want to be injured you
know why because if it goes down i'm
close to my family
oh okay i'm close to my friends
what am i gonna depend on my hollywood
friends to come save me
nope nope losing who's gonna come save
me no joey
no i mean i would come save you and get
you out of there with the kids if i was
there but
a lot of people don't think that way
right yeah when you're out in l.a
so i didn't want any problems i had a
little girl i already bought a gun off
the street
and i was like you know i don't need
this in my life at 57.
no i'm up in i'm up in studio city
they're robbed in
catalytic converters they were having
parades around the block from my house
there was homeless people everywhere
it was the end anyway yeah you know so
for me it felt like the end i feel you
yeah it was it was a mess down there i
wanted my daughter to grow up on the
east coast
i wanted her to be at the east coast
toughness tour
i didn't want her to grow up allergic to
peanuts and [__]
and you know i didn't that's not going
to [__] happen
don't you hate that [__] i [__] all
that [__] drives me crazy
i mean look i'm a crunchy hippie myself
but after
i'm also an italian from queens you know
what i mean like there's got to be a
balance to this [__] there's a balance
i'm a hippie too
i lived in boulder for 12 years
i love buddhism i went to naropa
institute
you know but no [__] you and your
[__] peanuts
[__] you and your [__] hummus yeah
you don't need hummus either you know
no no my kids are like give me [__]
grilled cheese
string cheese waffles mac and cheese
anything that's got
cheese in it put it in front of my mouth
hummus my kids would throw hummus at my
face if i tried to give it to them
oh my god it's so terrible that stuff so
here there's no hummus
the only problem here is everybody's got
pizza everybody's house you go to
so i got to do my weight watchers here i
got to do jumping jacks i got to ride a
bike
because every day somebody shows up with
something
i haven't even bought enderman's yet oh
yeah
you get the banana crunch pie no no
i'm telling you if i start i won't stop
so i can't even do it
i'm i'm scared of the holidays
that's right i go to the gym three times
a week i ride my bike
i do as much as i can do because i know
this is fat man villain you blow up here
so i've lost weight since i've been back
so i'm good so
the gyms are open there yes can you
believe that
no everything i know my friends were
partying in williamsburg last night in
the park i was like what is going on
i am so isolated my daughter goes to
school four days a week gee
oh so she's done yes the catholic
schools are going to school
five days a week just a half hour from
here
wow we're shut all the way down man
no [__] at least here i do comedy like i
told you last night
i know 25 38 people
at vinnie's comedy club but it works my
friends went to snl last night to see
dave chappelle i was like what do you
mean you went to snl isn't it shut down
well they have like a limited audience
you know maybe like eight people in
there
yeah they're trying to keep a little
normal here but the sad truth is they're
probably gonna end up shutting it down
you think so i'm flying here friday yeah
yeah they're probably gonna shut it down
so get ready
why i think our numbers rising again yes
yes they're going up here yes here they
are and
we have to get tested um
tomorrow and then show that to the
national guard
when we when we land in new york to get
let in
from the airport yes
that's crazy how long how long are you
going to be in new york for
i'm supposed to be there until december
1st
okay yeah i haven't seen my mom i
haven't seen my family i haven't seen
anybody and i want to see if i want to
move back east
okay well you know you got help here
i got your back if you need something
you know that
i don't know where the hell i would live
i only want to be in manhattan that's
what i'm used to
well you know what since you have the
kids you might have to make exceptions
you might have to go up to connecticut
maybe new jersey
maybe joey no don't say statin islands
yeah you got to go back to yours take
your kids back to your roots
i wish i still had my house in queens i
would move right into this
queens is a great neighborhood you know
i don't know what's going on in your
neighborhood now though
that's the thing they're saying
different things about new york city so
or maybe go back to long island go out
to the island it's nice
up there i only know queens that's it
and then that we have a house out at the
beach
those beach houses are a big deal right
now
how about north carolina
hell no they got a little they got where
my friend duncan lives they got a little
hippie community
you mean like asheville i would get down
with you yes
yes that's what i'm saying that's what
i'm saying we're looking in nashville
nashville too but you got you're gonna
move a lot you're gonna be around the
200 same people you're around now
when you go to nashville it's half of
california now it is i know
i've heard my my wife is from nashville
i couldn't walk you two hours out of
nashville
i could have gone to tennessee it's a
town called
bradford okay i don't know that
no nobody [__] knows that's where
they put witness relocation people
they put them out there oh my god
there ain't no not that it's like even
past jackson
it's out there i like it i like it
i mean not in the town town but i like
it like you know on the out a little bit
on the outskirts it's cool
outskirts would be cool for you that'll
work for you
what else do you like that's about it i
would do nashville and i wouldn't think
about laying down
roots i would go for a year or two um
unless i'm on a farm area then maybe
i'll stay
you know if i have some land but um i
just want to get back
all the way home back to new york all
right we'll come back to new york we'll
open up a medical marijuana store
yes and we'll make a million [__]
dollars wait how do you
how do you deal with the weed situation
there there's no weed
oh yes there's weed no but there's no
but it's not it's not legal right
like here no it's not but it's legal
wherever i'm standing
so they gotta bring you a dime bag every
[__]
wherever i'm standing weed is legal
don't worry about nothing i got that
covered
this is the home deliveries that used to
be the jam the home delivery
they got home deliveries in new york
they ain't got no home deliveries where
i live here
i got to do my own stuff here but i'm
all right i got the california weed
i'm still smoking that 30 i got edibles
i got teas i got sprays i got mints
i'm a man of many mysteries there's this
company that sent us a weed box that was
the coolest
[__] box of weed ever
um all the canisters what the hell is it
called
um it's uh it's
the the runoff of the water is from
the mount shasta do you know this
company
it's uh no oh man it's going to drive me
crazy now i need to look
drink are you drinking your pot right
now
no i'm to be honest here i thought i had
waters down here i got no waters
all i had with the refrigerator was the
stella oh for you
so i drank a stella i don't even drink
i'm drinking out of respect for you so
you know
so you don't drink a glass of red wine
alone you know what i'm saying
i got i'm drinking freaking water over
here i've been working all day
all right i've been drinking enough
water no water
i went yeah i went i went to get a water
but like i said i had no waters down
here so i just took a beer
i said how am i gonna talk to the
princess without a cocktail in my hand
i'm gonna find you this um this company
this company is
crazy they need to send you something oh
what is the [__] name of it
i mean they send you like this lighter
this gold lighter
that um you know like heats up and the
thing
and then uh three different crazy weeds
with the with the grinder but
but it's all like really beautiful like
the way they send that box of weed
is how good was the weed though
you know i don't really smoke it anymore
because uh
but everybody else does around me so
there were other people here
that were smoking the weed no edibles no
more nothing
the edibles no i was always a joint
smoker joints and bongs that was my that
was my thing
i i liked them when i was a kid i would
have
permanent cold sores going in a circle
around my
face from passing that [__] bong
around
it was just oh my god i was a disgrace
a disgrace with a circle around my face
i was a really crazy pot smoker and then
i stopped when i had my kids
because i i was getting i was one of
those people that had attacked
it attacked me my best friend attacked
me
you know what i mean when you just start
getting that paranoid crazy
but that's not true no yes it was when i
had my kids because when i was doing
joey we were smoking tons of weed
um no more nothing
i miss it i love the way it smells
anybody who's smoking weed around me i'm
like
but yeah this great company sent me this
weed and i can't think of the damn name
of it and i feel
terrible because they would probably be
so happy that i shouted them out on your
show
well where would you have anything there
nothing hidden
wait a second i got this
there you go i knew she had something
you know the deal guys you always save
your stuff
i'm happy you guys are enjoying this
here and uncle joey joint
with my girl dream d she's the real deal
it comes in this box oh it's called a
golden
state there you go give them a shout out
golden state
golden state and it comes in this box
and it says uh
highest quality flower grown from shasta
snow melt
for recreation and relaxation um i have
no but
but the the way they send it in this box
that [__] was straight up sexy well it's
very nice
i got a couple of boxes sent to me and
they even send like
lenses to you look at this
one company who is this this is
i can't see without my glasses
this is source and they sent me one of
these things
like like a diamond dude you know what
i'm saying oh look
what do you do with that so you can look
at your hairs on your wii
i can look at my ball heads with this
stuff like this i can't
i can't [__] see him they give me
this little thing
like what am i gonna do with this little
thing but it's cute it's part of the box
and i kept it as a souvenir
so i'm shouting out one of my favorite
weed companies source
so we both get to shoot somebody out see
what i'm saying look at this we just did
freaking
weed commercials on your on your show i
forgot that we were
that we're doing a podcast over here
that's all right we're family man
i'm i'm happy you made time for me
tonight i know you're busy
i know you're a parent you got the kids
i want to interview
you well when do you want to do that
what do you don't want to do it right
now
on your show i want to know about the
[__] many saints of newark but i know
you're not allowed to talk about
any of it you talk about what
i want to know about the many saints of
newark and how your experience was but i
know you're not allowed to talk about
the show
but can you at least tell me how your
experience was
okay i'll tell you the truth my
experience
from a to z was tremendous
um i went on there as a comedian
actor kind and the first day i thought i
was being cute
and david chase sent the word to me you
know like
just stick to the lines oh yeah
and i finally and i stuck to the lines
i did what i was supposed to do and the
second day
i learned so much because it was
one of those scenes of david chase where
something happens and then there's a gap
of air
and you're supposed to laugh at that gap
of air and i finally
saw how he did that once
once i saw his magic i
stopped everything i was doing and i did
everything the way he wanted
done interesting i love that story
so i went on there as a comedian but i
learned from him
because you know how twisted his mind is
yeah
and he he's a he's the master of dark
comedy
without even doing it you know i enjoyed
every single minute of it
the 12-hour days i did not complain one
time
one time they unwrapped me i smoked a
joint
i walked to the corner i got an uber and
they came back and told me i had to get
back wrapped and and usually i would say
something
i didn't even say nothing i told i went
back in there and i said
that i was unprofessional for being high
and we laughed our asses off at four in
the morning
you know i love that
uh i loved david i loved his wife
uh it was just great for me if i don't
act again
i'm good because that's exactly what i
said after the sopranos
if i don't act again i'm good i'm cuban
i'm from northern new jersey it made my
year and that's it that's how i feel
right now
i don't act again and i got to work with
alan king
king so he did like three of the
episodes
and he was great wait three of the
um it wasn't alan taylor alan taylor i'm
sorry allen king what was i thinking
alan taylor
but he uh he did it to see that it's one
movie no
or is it a series right no he did three
episodes with you guys
oh oh yeah yeah yeah but he did
i don't know how many he did i think he
did a couple i don't know i'm just
saying three
but i got to work with him and he was
great everybody was great
did you work with ryan yes
that's my boy yes
yes all right you guys got him right
after we got through with him
yeah he was great and he wanted to work
with david so
badly i mean because he loved the
sopranos
so he was pumped to be doing that
it was a real pleasure i loved john i
loved everybody on the set
alessandro i thought everybody was great
i'm excited to see the finished
product how was little michael
little michael was phenomenal yes
what a sweetheart of a kid i just found
the picture i just found a picture of
him today in my phone
we took a picture on the and i compared
it to the first time we took a picture
and he grew so much but he looked great
wow
he was a sweet kid i got to talk to him
a lot like i said it was just
it was just a great experience i'm so
excited to see it i can't
wait till it comes and i wish
i don't even know what the movie's about
i i barely remember my scenes now
you know it's like it was i was such in
it
yeah i got to stop smoking plus
the anxiety from the uh from the
pandemic
my my memory is gone you know i know
so but i had such a great it was a great
experience
and you know i got hired to do the
sopranos right
i got hired and fired yeah to play big
[__]
his brother no remember in the auto body
shot
were you on it no i didn't shoot it i
got fired before i could do it
why were you why because
georgine said that i told somebody i was
shooting it
and it was against the privacy act of
1964 or something
oh my god they were that [__]
precious about
even just showing up to play a small
part
yeah well when they called me they said
they said they think it was gonna be
like two episodes they didn't really
know
they were trying to look for the right
person or whatever i was shooting
spider-man too
and i went home and had to put the
audition on tape it was like one of
those auditions
i had to put on tape in la and i sent it
but i had read for the first i think the
second season
she called she saw me doing comedy in
new york
and she made me come in to read for gigi
yeah i mean i read for everybody i went
to producers a couple times in the
beginning yeah
i did not know yeah my hands were
shaking
when i went i had to walk over that
bridge
it was hot out i had my little mafia
suit on i had to walk over to brooklyn
bridge
it was like 90 degrees out with humidity
and like i could do this i walked over
the bridge
so yeah my experience and then you know
you look at your experiences when people
say no to you in acting or anything else
and i remember one day i was getting
ready in the morning to shoot
the prequel the many saints and i was
like how lucky i would was i that i got
fired
and now i'm shooting this if it's meant
to be
it's meant to be so you see how life
works as an actor
sometimes a no is better than a yes
because you got it later on you know so
totally that's a really good stroke of
luck with that one
they never even um had a big [__] never
had a brother on the show
did he end up having a character he did
yeah yes yes
some guy came in for a day and
he had a scene with uh phil leotato
oh so later on after he died yeah yeah
it was later on that they died i see
i see wow
that's awesome i'm so happy you're
honest did you do you have a lot of are
you in it a lot
uh
[Music]
you can't say i love it you got you had
to sign an nda
yeah and i had it just you know the
whole thing i just
decided that i wanted to do this
everything i did
dream there was always a glitch when i
did
spider-man 2 i busted what's his
favorite balls i mean he loved me to do
that but like i would smoke pot in the
green room
it was a samurai who was sam raimi sam
raimi
so i would come in the morning and sam
would tell me i was too big for the
train
he's like joey you're too big to be on
the train go to your room
so i would go to my room and i would
smoke pot
and then i would go to sam and say sam i
got to talk to you and they go what i go
somebody's smoking pot in my trailer you
better knock it off because you know i'm
a christian
balls every day you know i'm the longest
shot i act like an animal
you know i was acting like an animal so
everything i did
i never really respected it like an
actor just the many saints in newark was
the first time i went in there
and i said if i do this i'm doing this
i'm going to be a gentleman i'm going to
act right
i'm not going to complain about the
hours i'm not going to say anything
i'm just going to [__] do it and
that's exactly what i did
yeah working with david chase will
inspire that
because he is he's the godfather man
it's like i said if i don't work again i
could give a frenchman's [__]
yeah i thought yeah you know
i got to work with him i got to work
with raymie who cracked me up
i just bumped into him about a year ago
had a pitch
and we hugged each other and he told me
he goes i heard you talking about me on
all those podcasts
so you know it was great working with
adam it was great working you know
i had a great listen i'm an ex-con
that got in trouble and yeah then i got
into comedy
so for me lovely
this is like a cherry on the sundae you
know
so what what happened with the last
podcast you dissolved that one right
it was eight years and i felt that
we had done our run with it and it was
time to move on
you know you want to walk out of a room
like the sopranos
i didn't want to walk out of the room 15
years out with no ratings do you know
what i'm saying
uh-huh i had done a podcast two years
before that
and now i had done a podcast for eight
years
uh my co-host was great i loved him to
death
but it was just time to do something
different you know
so you have to talk you weren't alone
yes
no no no he was he started with me also
but the problem was that
i couldn't move him here for two days a
week
right right right you know i was taking
too much of his life
for two days a week he's 32 years old
he doesn't have a family you know and he
was basically in l.a to work with me
you know he was doing he was doing a
little stand-up and stuff
but that was it he's got a family i
didn't want to leave him in la by
himself
but it didn't justify bringing them down
here
and moving them all the way down here
for two days a week
so how do you like doing it by yourself
it's been uh great mike is great
i love doing it you know it's just
getting the chops
and being emotionally prepared and i
gotta tell you something
lately i don't feel emotionally prepared
you know i'm happy
everything's great but i think it's my
my i think my mind is in mourning
because i lost stand up
and especially after we lost you know i
was at the comedy store three nights a
week
sold out with bill bird joe rogan you
know harry wong
whitney cummings theo vaughn maj gibrani
i'm down here with all these stars
ron white and then all of a sudden it
gets pulled from us
you know yes the financial ramifications
is one
thing that's i understand that and i
took that like a man
uh i don't think my mind and my heart
could take you know not going to the
store anymore
yeah you know not not yeah i don't miss
la
but my soul misses something so
i'm in jersey i'm around good people my
daughter's happy
my wife is happy i think by doing
stand-up once a week and staying
sharp in time i'll fall in love with it
again little by little
like i didn't do it wednesday night and
i really missed it
i was doing it every wednesday and i
didn't do it one wednesday and i really
missed it
that's why i went back down there last
night did they open any of the spots in
new york
no everything's closed in new york they
are still there
there's a couple spots that are doing
illegal shows you know
they're trying i understand it
but i don't want to go to them because i
don't want to get hit in the head by a
[__] pipe
i'm not in the mood right now to get hit
the [__] head
so when new york gets dark that's when
all the [__]
crazies come out i know i'm not the move
for hand to hand combat
they punched that poor rick moranis in
the head
that dude never did nothing nobody that
poor little guy he's like i haven't
touched
rick miranda's got bit slapped up at the
upper west side
my old neighborhood about three weeks
ago four weeks ago
somebody else yeah no no it's all crazy
in new york people come up to you
and knock you in the head for no [__]
reason that i love you
i love it i just i don't need that right
now so
i need that i need to get hit in the
[__] head with a chrome while i'm
walking down the street
so here i am here i am 23 years later
that's it
and now i'm just a dad that does a
podcast
do you have more kids no that's it this
is your old this is your baby this is it
this is my baby this is my bodyguard and
what a gift
yeah i got a second chance man that's
beautiful
i love it i love that girl you have a
girl
so why push the you understand my a guy
in my position i could have pushed the
envelope
why push the envelope i got my wife
we've been together 20 years i got the
baby
she's seven she's gonna be eight in
january
we live in jersey we're secluded with
nice i got deer
i got a lot of trees around my house
i've got deer
i got italian food down the corner i got
chinese food and i got my gym
i got everything i need that's all you
need what about some cuban food you
don't need a nice melianoche
you know what man it's been i'm gonna be
here three months pretty soon and i
haven't had cuban food yet
my wife isn't cuban but she made a lot
of
nah my wife is irish oh
did you make it make you some bangers
and mash
yeah oh no no she she cooked some wicked
stuff for me you know me i like that
i'm cuban but i like white food i like
meatloaf i like
mashed potatoes but now i'm in jersey i
got my [__] chicken cutlets
oh be careful with those i got my
chicken cutlets
the best we make them here all day long
we always have them in the fridge
my wife makes them but the best thing
about jersey is they celebrate shoprite
oh i know oh tremendous they sell saw
my shop right they saw them at the
italian market oh yeah it's tremendous
so we always got chicken cutlets
yep i love me some chicken cutlets we
make them real
skinny and we we let them
sit in the eggs and the parmesan cheese
for a little while
before we read them they're delicious oh
with some mashed potatoes and some cream
corn with jalapenos in it
you're going to be 800 pounds by the
time you finish that meal
anytime soon and a nice glass of club
soda with a little cranberry juice in it
forget about it i like a nice splash of
cranberry
and then after that you sit down you
take your shoes off and you smoke a
[__] number of death
and you stare at the wall for an hour
and think about your life
and then you eat it all over again and
then about two in the morning you wake
up
and you tell your wife don't put them in
the refrigerator put them in an aluminum
foil
and save them on the stove yeah like a
[__] animal
i don't know how i do it i at two in the
morning i sleepwalk to the [__]
kitchen
and i just devoured two [__] chicken
cutlets oh yeah with a glass of water
with
right from the we got the water with the
refrigerator with the ice cubes
nice i drink the water and i go right
back to bed i wake up in the morning i
have a piece of chicken in my sleep
apnea from machine mask
it's hysterical
you wear the thing oh yeah you gotta
you gotta wear the whole thing right not
the whole thing i just said like i look
like a martian at night
i got like a little mask he couldn't
no wear lot of people can't wear it i
wear it because i know it's going to
save my life
yeah it's true you know you need to get
that oxygen man when you're sleeping get
all that oxygen
in there no i fall asleep on the couch
watching tv and i dropped 118 pounds
since then
did you really yeah i was 418.
what yeah i was 400.
yeah now i'm down to like three 301 298.
oh you are you're tall 295 511
510 that's pretty tall that's not tall
oh i'm just i'm a stumpy italian man
that's all i look like
my [__] ex is five foot six so you're
tall
yeah i mean
but your ex your ex is the man dog you
know what i'm saying
well he made some beautiful babies
that's for sure
good i'm happy that he does that he can
make good music too
yes yeah he's awesome he's awesome he
makes good music
he does are you you're dating now
correct
yeah i have uh um you know i just go
through different um
different uh instruments in the band
basically
i've just been working my way through
the different parts like
now i'm in the percussion department so
i'm dating a drummer right now
my last boyfriend was the bass player
right
they're not only one band okay i thought
you were dating the bass player from
uh coverdale's band right i was
i was not anymore now i'm being friends
with the old bass
player from white snake who rudy rudy
i've met rudy a million times with my ex
he's a dog yes
rudy's a dog and his brother too there's
two of there's two sarzos
yes right but rudy's a doll
yeah he's there you should go on his
podcast when you get a minute
i think my ex just went on his podcast i
saw a thing
um but yeah i'm dating uh
i got a really young boyfriend now who's
now
you know i've never dated a drummer so
you know it's a drummer this time
okay hey whatever whatever makes you
happy man i just want you to be happy
i'll be done with musicians after the
stint i'll be done with that
maybe a nice the nice carpenter next
nice nice carpet who can build me a
house
something you need something an
ark or something
this will be an ark i'm gonna go put my
daughter to sleep
i love you dread i love you for taking
the time to do
i love that you're going to put your
baby to sleep that's nice
i got to go wish her a good night
because tomorrow is school yeah
at 8 30 she gets on the bus so i'll get
up in the morning and see it
but i appreciate you i'm a fan and now
we're friends yes so you have my number
if you're in new york and you need
anything please reach out
and uh read to your daughter skippy john
jones with your best cuban accent
i do it with a mexican accent but read
that book to her
it the kids love it skippy john jones
let me write it down i'll write it down
seriously
is the best skinny john jones
skippy john jones yeah skippy
skippy john jones yeah
it's about a cat who thinks he's a
chihuahua it's freaking amazing
you know what i got a cat that thinks
he's puerto rican so oh
you like it i love you dread thank you
for coming on
joey stay in touch thank you
all right bye
yo i hope you enjoyed randy mateo i like
at the end now she goes [__] it
let's interview you [__] that's
what i call a guest right there
i hope you enjoyed it she was [__]
great man and i'm excited about the
soprano movie they did some uh
showings this week i got a couple people
who hit me up
some people really enjoyed it some
people
had to complain you know you know how it
is but uh i enjoyed it
i enjoyed my interview with drea i can't
wait to
watch 12th and many saints comes out i
have a lot of personal reasons you know
uh
just the fact that i worked with david
chase how i said in the interview
means the world to me and kicked me up a
level whether i [__] knew it or not
as a comic as a stand-up and as a human
being
and as an actor it's [__] weird what
it did to me i
i'm like the who in 76 we won't get
fooled again you know what i'm saying
i'm only working with the best from now
on but hey
i'm happy you enjoy um i hope you
enjoyed this week's episode
it's [__] monday we got a whole new
week coming up
third wednesday i'm at uncle vinnie's
[__] thursday night
i gotta do uh ryan sickler's podcast so
we'll do another
event on there i gotta do adr for the
sopranos i got a bunch of [__]
and do not forget november 25th
starts my stint on ozzie's boneyard
from the 25th i think to november 30th
every day
i will post up the times i am very proud
to be on aussie's boneyard
you guys know i grew up being an ozzy
osbourne fan
and when i got the call this made my
[__] day
patreon you know i love you
[__] we're moving straight
along this podcast
has nothing to do with patreon patreon
you guys get what you guys get
instead of giving you two [__] movies
uh
how many weeks we've been giving you
four we don't give a [__]
we had a cut back on the crowd storm
whatever the crowd
whatever the crowd source because we
couldn't have all 14
000 people on that so we're coming up
with a replacement
you got you know you guys know i always
email you i always answer back your
request
and i'm always posting up something so
we're always having a great time
over there on patreon a little bit more
personal none of the [__] political
[__] you see on all the other
platforms and we're trying to get your
merch under your [__] tree
by december 25th who's better than your
uncle joey i care about you
acceptance you guys think i'm here
smoking dope or whatever no
i'm here to let you know you're going to
be fine
we're going to get to get through this
and in time this will be laughing about
this [__] pandemic
and everything else that happened in
your life this week
is my 33rd anniversary of me kidnapping
ken bella
that's coming up on wednesday i'm sure
we'll talk about it
maybe do a little a review on it or
whatever you guys know the story
but i've been thinking a lot about it
because the united steven cigar was on
about
above the law and i thought i had seen
that movie the night before i turned
myself in along with
lethal weapon but when the movie starts
it says whatever of 88
so i'm a little [__] confused so i'm
gonna do some research on the dates and
whatnot because i'm a little [__] up
like i said i lost a half ounce of wheat
uncle joey never loses his [__] weed
i know where every [__] stem is seed
whatever i'm accountable for everything
so when i'm losing weed you know my
memory is [__] going
but hey i'm getting older i'm getting
wiser and i'm getting [__] better and
stronger here
and i'm happy i made the move i'm happy
everybody's healthy
and happy and i'm happy you guys could
watch me on a monday morning
stay black have a great week the album
of the week is a great show i do on
patreon
if you're not on there it's ten bucks
for the [__] month
what do you give a [__] that's two
starbucks [__] coffee
you don't need to be on that [__]
line wait like the rest of those sheep
i saw a line in front of starbucks off
coffee yesterday
off of route 9 i almost pulled over and
called them all [__] suckers
and two doors down there's a dunkin
donut selling that [__] brazilian
bold isis coffee
and they had two people at the [__]
door you make this you make the [__]
call
i want to thank uh everybody to watch
this week
and here's for a word from my sponsors
thank you
have a great week and see you wednesday
morning
tip top [__] magoo [__]
all right i want to thank you guys i
want to thank dria de mateo
but i want to thank our sponsors listen
mack weldon
tremendous i got the long underwear i
got three pad because you know what it's
going to get cold down here i don't know
much about what much
i'm no [__] meteorologist but i know
it's gonna get cold and mac walden
covers me with socks shirts hoodies
underwear
polos and shorts mac walden is
comfortable and versatile
they are basics you can use every day i
can wear it at the gym
a show or a dinner it works everywhere
in fact i wear my long underwear at
night
when i'm watching tv with my little
hooded sweatshirt
to keep me warm i look like a [__]
whatever but i love them
because they keep everything in place
and now with their loyalty program if
you spend 200
you get 20 off every order you make next
year
what get your shopping in today and save
for next year mack walden wants you to
be comfortable they really do
and their products are comfortable so if
you don't like your first pair
of underwear you can keep them and
they'll still refund you that's what i'm
talking about
no questions asked so what the [__] are
you waiting for
go to mack walden right now and tell it
it's gonna be cold
like rogan says i'm gonna do my first
winter and i'm gonna be calling him who
knows but i'm prepared
because i got walton long underwear you
understand me
so to grab the all black pack
for just 98 while supplies last
visit mackwalden.com joey
max walden mack weldon wants you to be
comfortable
so you don't like your first pair you
can send them back
and they'll still refund you no
questions asked this is what i'm talking
about
plus they got the all black pack it
comes with a t-shirt
underwear and socks inside a backpack
so what you're gonna do is for the black
pack
just press in slash joint and pressing
code joint
and you'll get 20 off any other order
so let's say you get the black pack and
you want to get t-shirts and a hooded
sweatshirt and warm underwear
i'm going to get you 20 off that order
that's what i'm talking about
on a monday [__] morning all right
that's my
mackwelton.com joint promo code joint
for 20 off the all black pack
for 98 listen mack weldon
reinventing men's basics the joint is
also brought to you by blue chew
tremendous remember when you woke up in
the morning your dick was so [__]
hard you can put it through a wall
those days are over with why because
we're getting older
now you got to worry about your dick
whatever listen my dick still works but
you always want to bring
in reinforcements i'm saying why are you
going to show up with weak wood
uncle joey's got the fix blue chew
it's the first chewable dick pill same
fda approved active ingredients as
viatra
and cialis this isn't some [__]
you know horny pill from down the
[__] 7-eleven or whatever the [__]
important stories
this is science [__] sucker blue chew is
prescribed online by a licensed
physician
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line with like a
[__] mooc in your car
with a mask on and it ships right to
your door
in a discreet package nobody knows
nothing you understand me
blue chew is cheaper than the pharmacy
and you can take them anytime
day and night even on a full stomach so
right now you got a special offer
visit bluechu right there.com that's
bluetooth.com
and get your first shipment free when
you press code joey
just five dollar shipping and again it's
blue
like the color of your dick after you
take one of these pills
chew broochu.com use
code and hydrant
i want to welcome to the joint
tremendous
listen to me you gotta [__] stay
hydrated why
because hydration is what's gonna
[__] solve
all your problems you can't walk around
with no [__] fluid in your body it's
getting colder outside
and you can feel your energy getting set
don't get sick this winter hydrating
is the best thing you could do for your
health after a workout or a lap around
the block with my daughter
this helps uncle joey fill tip top
mcgrew
hydrate is a refreshing drink mixed
powder
made with four key electrolytes your
body needs
sodium potassium magnesium
and zinc for an extra boost try hydrant
immunity
it's got all the vitamins you want a b6
b12 c and d plus hydrogen is backed by
money back guarantee if you don't love
it we'll send you back a full refund
listen
everybody's trying to get your business
and everybody's not [__] around here
we're giving you a hundred percent back
so hydrate
save up to 25 on your first order what
the [__] are you waiting for
i got a special deal for you 25 off your
first order
go to hot drink hydrant.com joey and the
code
joey at check out health is well
don't risk it get 25 off at
drinkhydro.com
joey i love you [__] have a
great week
thank you and stay black
hmm
[Music]
so
you